[Music]
look what I become
every day
okay we got another special guest today
possibly the greatest voice in the game
I mean you'll hear it here in a second
Sebastian uh Gorka is a british-born
Hungarian American Media personality not
related to George Soros military and
intelligence
that's the first time anybody's done
that's good that's good and foreign and
former government official who served in
the administration of U.S president
Donald Trump as a deputy assistant to
president from January 2017 till August
25th 2017. he's got a book out not the
one Adam talked about but the latest one
that's out here the war for America's
soul
uh if you haven't uh followed him on
social his shirt game is on fire he
wears this unique shirt he's a big fan
of the FBI the fascist Bureau
intimidation and he's got a lot to say
about it so having said that it's great
to have you on the podcast today thanks
for having me but when are you gonna
find the guy who does the thumbnails
let's talk about it this is a serious
issue you're a handsome dude and the
thumbnail for you and me today is 40
pounds ago for me and you look ugly what
so who is this guy listen this guy who's
this guy bring him in here now let's arm
wrestle and I'm gonna crush it he's not
a fan now he's not working on this
podcast does he hate America
maybe maybe parts of it maybe he should
go somewhere else I I think afterwards
we should have a conversation with him
how about we do that let's talk tomorrow
we're trying to create jobs here not uh
by the way I'm actually curious who did
the thumbnail can somebody text me and
tell me this is the crappiest okay and
and you guys asked my team for you know
links headshots bio and
that's what you got to do right there
zoom in a little bit that's a handsome
looking man right there that's 42 pounds
ago he's 42 pounds ago that's when I was
two 60 okay well Sebastian you're a
pretty big dude how tall are you six
three yeah I mean Tom looks like a
little elf next to you right now Adam
what touch it just
sounds good well listen let's get right
into it guys we got a lot of things to
cover there's a lot of craziness going
on uh we got a few topics that I want to
speak to you about one is Casey DeSantis
a lot of stories that's coming up about
Casey DeSantis one is from New York Post
I'm sure you've read them a few things
on uh um Biden's low rating on economy
on immigration uh some say he has the
lowest uh rating as a president since
Adam and Eve it's a long time too to
have something like that uh long-time
Democrat former presidential candidate
makes return to politics to run rfk's
campaign and oust Biden I want to know
your thoughts on that Durham report Jim
Jordan urges Congress to use power of
the purse against FBI obviously the
other side is not doing anything about
it we'll talk reparations ban on Micron
uh China escalates microchip clash with
U.S
maybe we can talk about what's happened
with Fox after Tucker sure uh we'll talk
about the annual meeting attended by the
world's Elite uh has AI top of the
agenda they don't even hide it anymore
they tell you what meeting it's about
we'll talk about China and Taiwan
um I I'm really curious to know if you
do drink Bud Light so we'll talk about a
Wall Street Journal Story how Bud Light
blew it and a few other things but
before we get into this if you don't
mind for the audience that may not know
your background how you got to where you
are today if you don't mind taking a
minute sharing your background that'd be
great
sure it's hard to do in a minute but my
uh my father was an anti-communist who
created a secret students organization
in Hungary after the Communists took
over he was betrayed by somebody called
Kim philby a British double agent he was
arrested tortured and given a life
sentence at the age of 20. he was two
years in solitary two years down the
prison coal mine and eventually
liberated by the revolutionaries in
1956. he escaped to the West literally
across a Minefield with the 17 year old
daughter of a fellow political prisoner
who became his wife and my mother I was
raised in the UK two Hungarian parents I
spoke Hungarian as a first language and
then after the war fell I went to work
in the new Hungarian government the
first freely elected Hungarian
Government after communism I worked in
the defense industry in the defense
Ministry helping them get into NATO
because I'd served in the British
reserves in a military intelligence unit
so I was helping them get back into the
West did lived in Hungary for 15 years
met my beautiful American Wife in Europe
and then 9 11 hits an amazing man a
marine who was a legend one of the
greatest men I've ever known Nick Pratt
Colonel Nick Pratt a former CIA
paramilitary invited me to teach on a
counterterrorism program out of garmish
Pat and Kirk and we have a U.S base in
Germany and I was teaching a
counterterrorism course for four years
to our allies and our partners and then
um woke up one morning with my wife 2008
we literally looked at each other in bed
we woke up when he said time to go
communism screwed this country it's
going to take another 50 years I applied
for three jobs in the U.S VMI West Point
and National Defense University got a
job at ndu teaching canadaism to 0506s
and one stars and then I wrote a book
called defeating Jihad and somebody
called corally Corey Lewandowski rang me
up in the summer of 15 and said hey uh
Mr Trump would like to meet with you to
get some prep for the GOP debates on
National Security I said uh okay so I
went to Trump Tower sat down with then
Mr Trump for about 40 minutes
unbelievable discussion from the Civil
War to nuclear weapons to Isis to you
name it and then classic Trump move
there's only three of us in the room he
looked at Corey in the corner he said
I like this guy let's hire him so I
became I signed an NDA like Stormy
Daniels me and stormy
and then I started writing him policy
papers for the debates and then I ended
up in the white house as his Deputy
served there for seven years seven
months felt like seven years
um and then uh resigned because of
certain things we can discuss later and
now I have a national radio show with
Salem America First in a TV show and uh
news max called the Goku reality check
and I'm loving it I love it so uh the
the 2008 when you woke up you and your
wife you're like we gotta we gotta get
out of here what was the Tipping Point
for you you know what for me for me it
was one concrete thing so our kids
uh were uh in 2008 when nine and and uh
seven and they spent every summer in the
US because of my wife's family so they
were socialized As Americans I remember
one day they went to the little catholic
uh School in the village where we lived
about half an hour outside of Budapest
and one day I was watching the
playground and I saw this sea of of gray
kids with their heads down and not
engaging and I see two kids standing
upright looking people in the eye and I
thought
uh our kids are different and and I
realize there's a there's a saying that
is maybe apocryphal it's attributed to
uh yanoshkadar who was the creator of
goulash communism this softer kind of
Communism after Stalin died and
apparently somebody asked him in the
pilot Bureau why are you doing these
reforms why why are you slightly
loosening the grip on the people in in
communist Hungary and Kardash said
allegedly I find it much easier to bend
the spine slowly over time than to try
and break it suddenly so this form of of
you know watered down Communism had so
seeped into the blood that in 2008 I
could still see it in the kids and the
10 year olds and the nine-year-olds and
I said I've done my I've done 15 I'm in
the land of my forefathers I have done
15 years I've investigated the Prime
Minister for being a secret police
officer I've had death threats on my
family I want to live in a country that
I respect and I'd been working with the
US military for about four years and I
said I love these guys I want to work
for them in America and become an
American so that's why so last night the
Lakers are playing the Denver Nuggets
and they were swept and after half time
it's about 10 30 or something like that
I said I'm gonna watch the Soros
documentary because I had nothing better
to do and so it was uh uh I thought
you'd be having cigars I was wondering
which cigaba I could find we can take
you there right after this but so so
we're so we're sitting there and and I'm
watching the documentary this is the
2019 one I don't know if you've seen it
or not go ahead go ahead if you want to
pull it up this is the one that came out
in 2019. okay uh if you've not seen it I
think it's worth watching now here's a
part when I watched it the documentary
starts off saying you know everything
about him how people in uh Hungary CM as
the devil and all this other stuff and
he is this and he is that and we don't
want him here and we don't want him
there and you know all these other
countries he can't go into I think he
can't go into the Czech Republic I think
it was Poland uh I think it was Slovenia
and one other country that he couldn't
go into and uh and then the documentary
ends selling him as this Savior and you
know it's a very interesting documentary
I think you being from where you are you
ought to watch it so I'm I'm very
interested in this guy because uh he's
his legacy is not going to go away his
son is going to take over and his son is
going to do uh things and but his son is
not his father his son is not smart
he's not like his dad
the legacy is not in billions of dollars
to come after 38 year olds he's not like
his dad no so so so but this is the
question I got for you as a man that's
you know from there and you live there
how do they view George Soros you know
because in this country in America the
left this is their God this is their Guy
this is the guy behind closed doors
that's making all the decisions giving
money to an open Society organization
all these things right
e-s-g-d-e-i-c-i but but how does Hungary
view him and how do you view him you
know the the average plumber probably
hasn't doesn't have any idea
um the administration I worked for
Audubon in the 1990s we can discuss him
separately Urban has very effectively
communicated in the the media this that
this guy is anti-west he's bad he's bad
for hungry so if you've heard of him you
think he's a bad guy in Hungary in oh
absolutely oh absolutely absolutely I
mean you know kicking out the Central
University
no no I think the massive people like
who you right but but if you live in the
big cities if you follow politics right
uh if you're not you know they've this
Audubon has very effectively just
destroyed the left in in Hungary there's
there isn't really much of an opposition
left he had a two-thirds majority of of
uh the parliament he managed to change
the Constitution bring back Christianity
and all kinds of great things so so the
majority of people if they know of him
if they know of him know that he's a bad
guy because Orban has been very good in
his uh let's just say information
operations
got it so but why is he a bad guy why
because he because he hates what the
West is I mean he took Carl Papa's
concept of open society when he studied
underpopra in the UK and and he
completely perverted it into I will
decide what is good I will pick you know
it's it's like um you know gnosticism
right the heresy you know we have the
secret knowledge it's a little bit like
the the bad version of straussian
Politics the the a very small cotery of
individuals know what is good for
everyone and we will decide and we will
pick I mean it's like it's what you know
it's like the 70 prosecutors in America
what has he done here
he doesn't have to win presidential
elections where's the real power in
America it's local it's when you can put
a million dollars into Alvin Bragg's
race in New York a man who campaigned on
I'm going to put Donald Trump in prison
that's power when you put dozens and
dozens of your prosecutors who are
radicals who hate America into power to
put criminals back on the streets to say
you know we need we need uh Equity not
equality that that moment from what was
it the Bill Maher interview with uh
Bernie Sanders I don't know the
difference what's the difference
tell me yeah I mean yes what your bird
is you don't know the difference Bernie
well guess what George Soros knows the
difference and He is building Equity by
destroying people in America why though
why why what why does he want to do that
so so what I wanted to get into this
guys to see what wait look have you seen
the interview that they deep sixth of
him on CBS or ABC when they asked him
about what you did during the War I
think that's a lot of that is why I mean
you've got to understand this is a
Jewish okay you find this I mean if you
if you find it in 10 minutes I'm going
to be impressed okay he's asked on
camera about what he did during World
War II in Hungary as a 15 year old and
how he worked with the Nazis to collect
the wealth of the Jews of his fellow
Jews to collect the wealth before they
were sent to the labor camps in the
death camps and the interviewer says do
you feel any remorse for this and he
actually laughs
the guy laughs I saw that six million
people killed and you're part of the
initial phase of rounding them up by
collecting their wealth before they get
put on the cattle carts and you laugh
dude if you're trying to deal with that
if your conscience is eating you up for
the last 60 years that you helped the
Nazis and you're a Jew there's all kinds
of things because that's the one you're
talking about uh it looks like it yeah
all right you got you gotta Oliver from
me nicely done
my understanding is that you went out
with this protector of yours who swore
that you were uh his adopted guys yes
went out in fact and helped in the
confiscation of property from the Jews
that's right
I mean that's that sounds uh like an
experience that would send lots of
people to the psychiatric couch for many
many years
was it difficult
not at all not at all maybe as a child
you don't his mind you don't see the
connection
uh but it was it created no no problem
at all no feeling of guilt no I and
you're better than the guy Joe Rogan
uses
so so I mean that that could you imagine
doing that as as a what you're a Syrian
Christian a Syrian Christian imagine
you're helping as a 14 year old
persecute the Assyrian Christians yeah
so I'm really trying to figure out his
motive though like what is the motive as
a globalist I get it so uh look I can't
get inside his head I do not want to go
to that you know dantean sixth circle of
hell but what's the motive for the left
today we were discussing this before we
went live forget Party politics forget
you know r d I realized this a long time
ago this nation is separated by one
question do you love America or is
America the problem
it's that simple uh is America bad or is
it great he and everybody else who works
with him at the open Society Foundation
works for Alvin Bragg believes America
is the problem and also they have white
guilt even if you're not Jewish you have
white guilt how does BLM stop you know
getting you know five different mansions
for its founder if not white guilt the
problem in America is is racism you know
the problem it is racism but who's who
are the racists the white liberals those
are the people who are the problem in
America because they hate themselves and
they hate this country if you think
America is the problem it explains
everything open borders right it
explains you know why we're doing deals
with Iran it explains everything it is
hatred of America that is the key
question do you love it or you dear hate
it what's the antonym of George Soros we
don't have one we you discussed this
yesterday I want to know from you
because you're in this world yeah well
we had Sheldon Adelson who who passed
last year
um that this is the big big problem on
the right right is that we have people
with money who spend it on garbage I
mean seriously another full page ad in
the Washington Times that's not gonna
that's not gonna move the needle
anywhere we have not been playing the
culture War we're having fun look look
at look at what is being done in the
mainstream media the oh the only guy who
could be
is Elon
but he's not a conservative I was on a
an hour and a half Twitter spaces with
him and I got to ask him a question and
I listened to him this is the first big
Twitter space he did we had like 90 000
people on it
and he was on his jet I remember that
the whole soundtrack
and you know if you if you haven't
listened to it guys listen to the
Twitter space
by hosted by Mario nafal where we talk
about the Twitter drops and when I tell
him where's the Smoking Gun Elon I that
this isn't you know oh the the Democrats
in DC worked with the Democrats in Palo
Alto this is news and I said where's the
smoking gone anyway the thing about Elon
Musk is if you listen to that 90 minutes
he is like a kid who found a new toy
it's like Christmas day and you open the
box and I've got a new toy what's the
toy the toys politics I guarantee this
guy hasn't had a political thought for
the last 40 years and then up comes
censorship up comes open border up comes
everything else and he goes huh
what what what's this Hunter Hunter
Biden laptop thing
why why can't I retweet the New York
Post story about it before the election
he's found politics and he's playing
with it he doesn't know what he is he
doesn't know whether he's a Libertarian
or a conservative he just knows people
are attacking America that has given him
Fortune beyond belief and are attacking
the First Amendment and he doesn't like
it he could be he could be the George
Soros for the good guys but he's also
got some ties to China that are
problematic business ties whatever but
you know my metric when people say to me
you know he's he's just another one of
the elitists he's pissed off all the
right people in the last year the
enemies he has made are all the right
enemies from The Washington Post to CNN
to the Democrats the AOC if you're
pissing off those people who hate
America you're probably a good guy
yeah you know there's a um it's funny
you're saying that 40 years he's not you
know he just kind of got a hold of this
but knowing his style of a student and
curious he is I can only imagine how
obsessed and immersed he is with wanting
to know everything learn everything
about the space if that's the case if
you're saying that's the case uh and if
he becomes a True Believer uh that's a
pretty heavy weight of a truth do you
have any thoughts on the guy on the
person he just hired us yeah do you have
any thoughts on it I'm curious so I I
saw all this stuff about her being you
know she's a leftist well economic Forum
executive director look at the interview
she did with him it's all the work I
watched the interview it was it wasn't
wasn't bad and you know it's fascinating
the finance my engineer my radio show he
sent me a clip of the financial times
where it's two unnamed sources uh senior
Executives in advertising said yeah if I
had the class here I'd say Linda's
probably a Reagan Republican
and then I go to fight is this woman on
Twitter
and I go on Twitter
she's following me Patrick
now if you're watching your movies you
know you have to be I mean having me on
your show you got balls so God bless you
for having me in your show right because
as far as you know the left is concerned
I I am you know the the devil incarnate
you know Trump's what what did the
telegraph call me Trump's pit bull right
when I was in the white house if she's I
don't have a lot of big uh ad Executives
following me on Twitter I mean I've got
a million plus followers but big big ad
Executives I think she's probably the
only one now that's interesting and my
producer who has the best political
his the marrow bone he can he can sniff
out a a fake person instantly he said
yeah you know why he hired her
because the biggest problem at Twitter
now and you've seen it on your feed are
the crap ads I mean he's been hammered
since he took her over they have been
targeting him the left has to get rid of
his advertisers he needs to make that
platform profitable he wants to turn it
into the Amazon Plus Facebook plus
YouTube of the future the super app yeah
he says I want this that the app you
only need one app to shop and watch your
videos and do so this is the app now you
can't do that without money without it
being profitable he's just hired a
professional and he can fire her
whenever he wants this is a woman who's
there to bring in ad revenue and I I'm
not worried about this woman not at all
yeah I mean uh uh I've been following to
see what she's saying how she
communicates what she's doing she hasn't
DM me back so I'm waiting for him sure
she's got 50 000 views
me come on does that kind of pump it up
like if if it's follow to follow so it
kind of shows that my yeah I'm sure
she'll eventually get back does it show
how long she's been following you uh I
don't know I don't know about that's a
good question maybe in the you know back
back maybe it was something you said at
a particular moment that inspired her if
you're in the advertising industry you
know you don't follow Mega people
that's you know because somebody can see
that maybe that's why he hired her
because she has uh he's smart the
ability to have certain ideology but
also play ball with certain people on
the left and
Money Talks baby let's let's talk about
mango people let's talk about your
experience working with President Trump
and how that was and how you think he's
doing right now with all the polls
what's out there uh what's your
experience been with him that's what
everybody wants to know doesn't matter
where I am in the country what the topic
is they've asked me to speak on sooner
or later in the Q a the question is
what's he really like and the fact is if
you've been you know alive for the last
40 years if you've watched television if
you've seen you know president Trump the
nice thing about him and I live in DC
and it's full of snakes and Janna's
faced you know lies what you see is what
you get when it's just the two of you in
the Oval Office it's exactly the same as
if he's in front of 60 000 people in a
stadium exactly the same and and let me
let me tell you a story about that first
meeting in Trump Tower in in the summer
of 15.
you've got to understand I grew up in
the UK so step off step off upper lip
debating Club you know all very proper
blah blah blah and I walk into this kid
from Queen's office and the Donald's a
little bit different he's not exactly
from you know uh private school in West
London like I was
so I got a little bit of getting used to
but within three minutes of talking to
this guy I realize one thing
he hates political correctness and he
loves America and I said
you want me to work for you fine you
hate political correctness number one
number two you love America you think
about you know I was there when he
announced in Mar-A-Lago for the second
time
and of course I was there to You Know
cover it for my show and to you know
support him but I'm listening to it and
I'm standing there
and it blew my mind because what has he
been put through for the last six years
have you home rated by armed FBI agents
have your wife attacked have your son
attacked being called a anti-semitic
white supremacist when your daughter
converted to Judaism and your grandkids
are Jewish
and you're prepared to step into the
arena again
I salute that I salute that so um a
great American bottom line whether you
like his tweets or not when people say
the tweets seriously six million illegal
immigrants and you're going to talk to
me about tweets I mean grow up will he
just wait before well this is the I
don't know will he tweet that's the big
one the question there's a lot of
questions that's probably the most
important one yeah
um I don't know because of true social I
don't know what what deal he's got with
the investors at truth social whether he
can't we'll see he's got he's got a year
and a half does he follow he's on
Instagram he's using face using
everything but Twitter right so does he
follow you on Twitter Sebastian does he
[__] he only follows like 16 17 people I
figured you'd be in that list I don't
know well I haven't checked
okay so let's go through Durham report
okay let's talk about that so A few
things uh obviously there's a lot to it
I'll read the store now just pretty much
pee you up and you can go from there
sure uh with your background so
um let me go here so Jim Jordan urges
Congress to use power the purse against
FBI this is a Washington Washington
examiner story
um uh to hold the FBI accountable
following the release of the Durham
report Jordan urges argues that
Appropriations can be leveraged to
pressure the FBI into reform stating we
got to limit how they spend the money
maybe even limit them Jordan has been
vocal about FBI misconduct including
alleged targeting of anti-abortion
groups and conservative activists he
calls for further investigations and
discussions with individuals mentioned
in the Durham report stating are there
people that were highlighted in the
Durham investigation and the Durham
report that we need to talk to under
Judiciary Committee we're going to give
that a good hard look some Republicans
have even suggested defending orbolish
and the FBI yesterday I think a few FBI
whistleblowers came out the mainstream
media didn't give it a second of air
time at all they did not talk about it
so tell us what's going on why is
mainstream media not talking about it
with everything that's being shared
isn't this enough credibility for them
to want to look at this and if not why
are they not because the FBI works for
them the FBI Works to the left works for
the Democrats and works for the media
which is part of the left it's very
simple so when the done report is 307
Pages it's long but most Americans are
never going to read it so I tweeted this
out at the weekend and I I you know I'm
you know I've got a lot of followers but
I very rarely get 366
000 views on a tweet in a couple of days
and here it is it's just the cliff notes
haven't read the Darren report okay here
are the cliff notes the FBI and CIA knew
Hillary was about to frame candidate
Trump
repeat the FBI and the CIA knew Hillary
was about to frame Trump number two
Comey head of CIA
uh said FBI and Brennan head of CIA
briefed Obama and Biden on her plot on
the summer of 2016. before the election
Biden as vice president and Obama were
briefed by the CIA and the FBI that
Hillary's gonna do this may job she's
gonna lie about Russian collusion we've
got the Deeds
biggest conclusion there was never any
evidence of Russian collusion none zero
zip you know Muller investigation uh
impeachment one impeachment two no
evidence of Russia collusion
nevertheless the U.S government
illegally spied on the Trump campaign
and us in the Trump White House fisa
warrants Flynn Carter page manafort
Papadopoulos on and on and on and lastly
my conclusion this isn't The Cliff Notes
The Deep state is real but Durham didn't
have the balls to arrest any of its
leaders or their masters Hillary Obama
or Biden 40 years ago the FBI was the
enemy of the of the Left Right the
greatest patriotism is dissent we hate
the man we hate the G-Man today and this
this is tough for me to even say
because before I joined the White House
my wife and I had the only external
contract to provide training on Isis and
Al-Qaeda to the FBI I would think twenty
thousand miles a month going from a
field office to ra to the headquarters
to Quantico briefing the FBI training
the agents I trained thousands of agents
and SOS support staff and intelligence
analysts if the FBI knocked on my door
tonight I'd say screw you talk to my
attorneys if you've lost me
you I mean if you've lost Dan bongino if
you've lost me if you've lost you know
hardcore Maga it is irredeemable there's
no way to salvage this entity this
entity must be dismantled because we
have a political police force in America
and it's called the FBI
and it's not just about President Trump
or or you know Paul manafort or Steve
Bannon it's about you know Catholic
preachers in Philly having their home
raided by armed FBI agents it's about
January Sixers who didn't even enter the
building and get charged with a felony
that's political police I'm sorry but
how did that happen though if at one
point they were the anti-left when did
they become the anti-right so I just did
an interview with a guy who had 21 years
in
um Michael Van Meter he's a FBI guy
supervisory special agent it's on it's
on my America first uh ramble feed if
you want to watch it and he's fast he he
said this happened right after Louis
freed when Louis freed came in you
started to see lawyers being brought
into the leading positions on the
seventh floor in the Hoover building not
not agents and then after 9 11 Mueller
was told remember this is this is a
pivotal moment in FBI history Bush after
9 11 told Mueller the then FBI director
your job is to prevent the next 9 11.
hang on a second we're cops cops don't
prevent crime
cops arrest and investigate crimes now
the FBI is meant to prevent them which
means it becomes an intelligence service
not a law enforcement agency if you
don't believe me the the URL the the not
the URL the address for FBI employees
ends with DOT IC
it's fbi.gov dot IC why intelligence
Community they are now a spy agency but
they're spying on who
Americans that's the problem Muller
starts with free to a certain extent
Muller and then uh Comey turn it into an
intelligence agency with a political
prerogative now think about the fact we
just had this drop yesterday the fisa
court
issued well it took a year to get it a
report in which there were 270
um fisa warrants that were illegal
um not fisa warrants fisa surveillance
requests over a million Americans oh a
quarter of a million Americans what are
we talking about white supremacy is the
biggest threat to America I I this is
what the president said at a college a
week ago this is insanity this is I used
to give lectures on the FBI to new
agents and and Military Officers and say
you know what's really weird about
America
America is the only developed nation in
the world that doesn't have an internal
security service
there's no MI6 there's no bundes for
fashion shoots and like there is in
Germany in America
we don't we don't have political
security because of the nature of the
country and how we were born I don't I
don't give that lecture anymore because
we have a political police force and
it's the FBI and it cannot be redeemed
when you've got Dan bongino former
Secret Service guy say it's got to be
taken down when you've got people like
Steve Gray 23 years in the FBI say on my
show no irredeemable Carl serifin
whistleblower irredeemable give its
three main missions to other agencies it
doesn't matter who you change at the top
who you put into the seventh floor of
the Hoover building this agency is
irredeemable I look you've served you're
a specialist right I know that you or I
if you're in the Philly field office
and the assistance the super supervisory
special agent says Hey we've got this
warrant there's this guy Mark Hauck and
um he uh he uh pushed this abortion
protester at a Planned Parenthood Clinic
who was screaming at his 12 year old son
and they charged him with a misdemeanor
but the local Court dismissed it they
said you're protecting your kid this
guy's a loony we're not going to charge
you but we're going to go in there
anyway put on your ceramic plated vest
get your M4 load it we're going to raid
his home what would you do Patrick I
know what I'd do I'd say here's my badge
here's my creds I'm not your stinking
gestapo I resign how many are doing that
well 20 of them did it for Mark hauck's
house so here's here's why I don't buy
the Hannity thing oh it's just the bad
apples on the top floor [__] it's
not the the bad apples if you don't have
you've got tens of thousands of agents
and intelligence analysts and support
staff if you're not striking if you're
not outside the building picketing
saying we are not your gestapa
sorry you're one of the bad guys we've
got we've got less than 20
whistleblowers out of tens of thousands
of people at the FBI headquarters and
Across the Nation less than 20
whistleblowers
and you know it's really freaky nobody
from doj the people who give the orders
not one whistleblower why do you think
because it's that when I was in the
White House I realized very very early
on all of government is corrupt you know
when Obama's sick the the IRS on you
know tea party Patriots
it's all corrupt the worst the doj the
doj is literally a wing of the Democrat
party it's just a political tool can I
ask you a question regarding the FBI and
uh I hear what you're saying I mean you
make some very valid points especially
with the the news of the Durham report I
want to just go back in time a little
bit because we were he's Pat saying how
did this happen this is purely
speculation opinion
um we all remember in 2016 I think eight
days before the election it was James
Comey who went up on stage and
potentially as they say
cost Hillary the election he basically
said at this time Hillary's emails
Hillary's emails him he was sloppy as
hell he didn't charge her with anything
but basically said it was careless to an
extent and then obviously Trump won the
election
how much do you think that
yeah and we also remember when Comey was
still the FBI director he was in that
room like basically hiding behind uh the
the drapes he's six eight he's trying to
blend in do you remember that it was
like all right we see you Jim you're six
eight buddy but how much do you think
it's almost like a Mia culpa basically
on the FBI's behalf basically saying yes
we are the ones essentially responsible
for Trump
whether you agree with that or not that
they're basically reversing course and
saying all right we cost Hillary the
election so let's see what it's
polarization of the FBI for sure or the
reposition but going back in time to
Pat's question how did this all happen
this is just something that comes to
mind for me look that that press
conference is Infamous I mean you've got
to watch it again it's 13 minutes long
and for 12 and a half minutes Comey
lifts every crime she committed you know
18 tssci secret emails topped Intel put
onto a private server that that's at
least that means somebody goes into a
skiff goes into a secure facility with a
thumb drive which is illegal if you're a
US employee or with a camera which is
illegal to photographs classified emails
takes them out downloads them and then
sends them on an unsecured server to
Hillary's uh email system which is in
her bathroom right that's a that yeah if
I did that once if you did that once
when you're a specialist you're in the
brig and you ain't coming out you're
going in there for 20 years okay because
yes Espionage Act is clear intent is
irrelevant it's one of the few parts of
the US code where intent is whether
you're a spy or whether you're a [__]
like Aldrich aims and you leave your
briefcase or classified stuff on the
subway Metro on the Metro by accident
doesn't matter
it's classified information you go away
she did it 18 times in just that press
conference and the last 90 seconds he
said which isn't which he's not allowed
to do he's a director of the FBI he's
not the freaking AG says but no
reasonable prosecutor or judge would
bring charges against this woman
I had a body working in the Chelsea jttf
The Joint tourism task force in New York
he said there were people in the this is
an FBI unit that is interagency when
they heard Comey say that
they got up there was a Tuesday I think
a Tuesday they got up from their desks
put on their jackets left the building
and didn't come back till Monday they
were so disgusted by what he did which
wasn't helping Trump he exonerated her
he exonerated her and he has no right to
do this no reasonable person would bring
charges
excuse me you're not even allowed to say
that you're the FBI director you're not
a prosecutor you're not a judge and you
exonerate why because she's a friend of
yours because you want to stay in that
position he was trying to save her he
wasn't destroying her now it didn't work
out too well but his motivation was to
save her ass
why do you think Trump kept him on as
FBI director
it's ironic for a guy who's uh 14 season
long TV show whose motto was you're
fired right exactly between you and me
and your your viewers he hates firing
people
that's why he does it on Twitter so much
because he the person it just you really
does you're saying the guy who is most
known for people they're fired right
does not enjoy five people I don't know
if I'm buying now you don't have to talk
to talk to people who worked in the
White House like me and ask him you know
what he doesn't like doing that I don't
know why he didn't do it earlier that
guy should have been he should have used
his uh namesake in his catchphrase day
one with Comey don't you think he should
have yeah and with many other people
look you have to understand one thing
about President Trump and I love as an
immigrant having to remind my fellow
Americans who are born here you know
what you did in 2016. Americans did
something really funky in 2016. because
from George Washington to Obama there's
a connection every single president in
America every single president is a
member of the political Elite every
single one former Senators Congressman
Governors or retired generals
every single one Along Comes A Real
Estate Mogul from New York with a
reality TV show who's never run for any
I mean even Reagan couldn't win first
time this guy runs the first time
and he wins 64 million Americans as my
my body bongino says you know double
barrel middle finger to to the political
Elite elect somebody who's never served
as County dog catcher let alone the
president how does he know how DC works
he's not a politician who does how does
he know what come he's really like if
Comey you know Brown noses him this is
this is why round two is going to be
different if we do our part we get him
reelected dude
very different
very I said this in an interview with
PBS
and uh they stole it and they they
didn't run the interview but they used
my line as the the title for the for the
documentary with with Bannon and
everybody else people need to understand
when we walked into that building I
walked into that building January 21st
uh the day after the inauguration it was
a Saturday but I was on the clock I'm a
deputy I'm going into work when we
walked into that building they were less
than 20 less than 20 people in senior
positions like me who were Maga America
First and understood why 64 million
Americans said yeah we don't want a
politician
we had to fill 4 000 positions
presidential positions four thousand and
run a government of more than two
million people now uh
God bless Steve Bannon
but he actually said in an interview for
running stone or Vogue or some stupid
publication he had to use this word
two weeks into the administration we
didn't have enough bodies so reince and
I made a quote drug deal with the RNC to
fill the positions
I think that explains what happened for
the next four years
when you bring in bushes when you bring
in rhinos when you just have people with
a pulse but who hate them I I was a
deputy assistant to the president now I
didn't know what that meant okay because
I'd worked in the military and a DOD it
outranks a four-star general I didn't
realize that until I rolled up to DIA
for a lecture on this on on China
and they treated me like you know the
second coming I I you know the the the
the the the two stars are coming out to
greet me and take me to the VIP blah
blah blah you're Deputy there's only 42
of us in government 42 Deputy assistants
to the president
six months into my term I realized
there's another DAP in the building
another deputy assistant my rank
who detests the president
who utterly hates Trump and everything
he stands for which is weird because
being a deputy assistant to the
president you're not shanghaied you're
not giving the queen Shilling with a gun
put to your head you will be an
out-ranking four-star civilian no you
actually volunteered to do it but you're
in the what to get a check check mark on
your resume you're gonna come into a
building and work for a guy who you
can't
that's not going to happen again
so how do you think this time will be
different knowing what you know now if
you had people insulated in the
administration right that basically
hated Trump which is insane to me like
we have people like General Kelly I mean
think about General Kelly was the chief
of staff yeah that is one of the most
powerful people in the world and I love
them Marine Corps is my favorite service
I spent two and a half years teaching at
quantica I love the Marines and it pains
me to say he was a subversive he should
be in prison right now I mean to think
of this Corey Lewandowski
Good Buds with the president never
worked in the administration but he'd
come in all the time to talk to the
president and he'd never tell Kelly
Kelly would get irate he'd get pissed
and I can tell you this because Corey
said this in a fox interview one day he
was coming out of the oval Kelly saw
Corey grabbed Corey and flung him
against the wall so hard he ripped the
button off his jacket General Kelly did
that I said you don't effing come in my
building without my permission he was
chief of staff at the time my building
nobody freaking elected you to nothing
oh yeah you're a big you know Marine
retire nobody elected my building that
cannot happen again what are we going to
do about it
um there's only two jobs I'd be prepared
to do in the next Administration one of
them is Personnel
um there's another person who's already
been um
that given the nod yeah and he's a
friend of mine and if he gets it we've
had a discussion I'll help you in
whatever way you need Reagan said it
best policy is Personnel Personnel is
policy it doesn't matter what your issue
is I'm a big Second Amendment guy but
whether it's a sanctity of life whether
it's the Border whether it's economy it
doesn't matter what your issue is if you
don't get Personnel right
you're not going to get anything done
rule number one if we win if we do a
part we have to have a filter system
that only allows people who love America
into the building end of story so it's
not about Trump it's not about
Republicans people who love America who
would those names be meaning you know
the last because the criticism is some
of the older guys don't want to come
back you know this person's not coming
back daughter's not coming back cushions
nobody wants a job back everybody's kind
of hesitating who would be departed a
new team yeah so this is I'm working on
an article that's exactly those for my
sub stack you know the the names of the
cabinet and who should come in
this is this is a challenge
my friend has the morning show in DC
Chris Plante great radio host and he
said one of the greatest successes of
the left in the last 20 years is to
guarantee that good men and women will
never work in a republican conservative
Administration
and he's right why would you why would
you be a Justice Kavanaugh even why
would you risk having you know loonies
come to your house with zip ties and a
gun to kill you and your children I you
know I'm you I thought I was used to it
but then when I came into the
administration they came after my wife
they came after my son there was one
journalist who wrote 52 hit pieces in me
on me in two months one of which was
about my 18 year old son and used the
word traitor in the headline
about my high school age son why would
you do that
so it's going to be a challenge what I
said to Mike Flynn at the beginning the
National Security advisor I said because
we inherited a National Security Council
there's 420 people it was insane Obama
created this massive massive NSC and I
said Mike get rid of them all send them
back to their agencies because most of
them come from you know state or CIA or
DOD and put some good people at the top
of each one as senior directors and
let's fill it with people from the
campaign let's bring people who work
their ass off to get president Trump
elected who don't know the difference
between Sunni and Shia but give me six
months and I will train them I will I
will be there they will be there till 10
o'clock at night they will learn the
rudiments of national security and at
least they'll be loyal to the will of 64
million Americans and and you know a
week later Mike was fired
so you want to bring in Greenies or do
you want to bring in some big news well
I think we've got it we've got a year
and a half no we got it we got a year
and a half to find Cadre and to convince
people uh we've got to have the Top Line
locked in we've got to have the cabinet
members we've got to have the senior
directors we've got to have the dazdies
the assistant secretaries all locked in
but it can't be we I don't want to get
into too much in the way and tell me if
I'm talking too much
all the big appointments used to go
through our office through bannon's
office so we'd get these spreadsheets
every week of people who want to come
into the administration there was one
spreadsheet we received this is
unclassified of people who are applying
to the top jobs in the dod like
assistant Secretary of Defense Deputy
assistant Secretary of Defense and I
looked at the spreadsheet before I gave
it to Banner and I said
where are we getting these names because
there's a column on the right hand side
referred by
four of the people on this spreadsheet
had been referred by Michelle Flournoy
Michelle Flournoy was Obama's you know
top Pentagon official people people
actually coming into the Trump
Administration are putting Michelle
Flournoy I mean just put you know
podesta just put Axelrod away don't you
that can't happen again that cannot
happen again
yeah it's going to be you know that that
part is going to be uh interesting to
watch who's part of the cabin and who's
part of the team because some people the
criticism of uh uh first term was the
fact that the training of the swamp
didn't happen and I wonder is it is a
part of it
where you know you know how in fights uh
or you know a game you lose the game and
you know the opponent hug each other or
even in UFC hey man this was a great
fight you know you're really great you
know you really brought it and I got to
give some respect to him you know this
fight wouldn't be displaying you become
friends is it almost there's a side of
you when you go into this space that is
filled with you know backstabbing dirty
and you're like you know what I think
they're gonna be Noble so let me have a
meeting with Romney the next day you
know let me bring these other guys in
and then you're like let's make this
work maybe I can change them maybe if
they really see how good I am we can
really unify this group and then you
make the mistake of keeping the comeys
keeping everybody yeah no no no no no no
no they're not who you think they are
this is not capitalism this is not
business this is not corporate these
guys are darker and dirtier than you
think stay strong and bring True
Believers in is that the evolution that
he had to go through with his first term
you and also he's in a territory that
he's never been in before right I'm I'm
a geopolitics guy I'm a broadcaster
don't ask me to play your concert piano
it's not you will have a very bad
concert or who won the uh Celtics he
came nuggets or whatever it was right no
clue is that a cricket match right
um so he's in a completely new
environment but but to your point two
things let's talk about the left let's
talk about our side on our side The
Establishment really thinks he's a joke
he's an anomaly that the American people
just chose the wrong person by accident
they really I mean Chris Christie's
going to announce Chris Jabba the
heart's gonna announce it does he really
think that anybody in America is going
to vote for him I mean ASA Hutchinson
ASA Hatcher you could literally be a
diplodocus from prehistoric times and
you're running for the presidency The
Establishment thinks that Donald Trump
is a blip it's a it's an accident we're
gonna get back to normal and footsie
under the table the Democrats and the
sweet deals with China and will be fine
he's just he's just weird just an
accident it's perverse get back to
normal so you can't deal with those guys
because they think you're a freak
and the other side let me give you an
example
I was thrown in day three of the
administration right because we dropped
the travel ban and it was not well
communicated and I could see that it
wasn't being well communicated so I
texted Bannon on a Friday night I said
Steve you know we've got to explain this
better like this isn't anti-muslim this
is based upon a threat assessment that
Obama left us of the Seven Nations that
cannot tell us who the people are who
are coming across the border this is
their threat assessment we're just
initiating it
and and Bannon typical Bannon it doesn't
sleep 3 A.M he takes me back he says
tell Spicer now to use you now I didn't
go into the administration to do media I
went there to do behind the scenes
National Security so okay Spicer Bannon
says use me so I am literally dropped
into the pit of Hell the Saturday
morning Sunday Friday doing all the CNN
I mean this is the fun stuff that people
keep talking to me about when I
destroyed Cuomo when I was on with you
know MSNBC and I was a effective
communicator
after I was effectively communicating
all this stuff with the president
Senator Durbin wrote a letter to the
Secretary of Homeland Security to
investigate my naturalization and to
have me
kicked out of the country
Dick Durbin from Illinois
these this is this isn't a political
difference
this is what when the other side thinks
you must have lied on your immigration
papers you must be deported because
you're an effective Communicator for the
president
right
this isn't politics this isn't you know
Tip O'Neill having a beer with Ronald
Reagan
you know Friday night every left wants
to destroy us every week they got
together
every week once upon a time there was a
time in this country where tip and Yip
would get together and have lunch in
Rose Garden and there was a certain
nobility of it
um and where they were let me ask you a
question but let me just add to that
think of think about what Brennan has
said Brennan John Brennan still has his
security clearances he's a former CIA
director he on National cable television
he said the incumbent president
is a Trader who works for Russia
excuse me I mean politics has been dirty
for a long time
but to say the guy in the White House
actually works for the Kremlin
that's not politics
that's evil
you've got a good playbook on the people
you're talking about here but right now
when when you get into all these
presidential candidates and people
coming in
um
you you've got to read on this because
I've always observed it and seen as it's
one of two things I want a cabinet
position or I want the VP slot and these
are the B candidates that are running
and saying well I'm going to deliver
bundled donations and my support you
know once I bow out which will be 11
minutes after South Carolina remember it
used to be New Hampshire Iowa South
Carolina something of those before the
calendar got effort with right and so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to do
here I'm going to whisper that okay Hey
listen I've got six and a half million
dollars in the war chest I'm gonna back
you up how about Commerce and they're
like okay I respectfully bow out after
South Carolina and I said please get
behind this candidate and and there's
almost this this this what you are is
your proxy campaigners right how much of
that is going on right now and who do
you think is legitimately serious that
actually thinks delusional or not that
they can make it and who is how there
that are really just self-nominating and
auditioning as part of this meat grinder
process yeah this may shock you I don't
hang out a lot with politicians because
I don't like them so but you have a
Playbook I have a plan you have a mental
place but can you have eyes to see and
ears so what do you think here are the
Dynamics let me just expand upon upon
your analysis a little bit so yes number
one this this kind of aggregating of
funds and then passing over to the other
guy and hopefully you'll get you know
kick back and you'll become a member of
the cabinet absolutely absolutely more
important is the ego and this is what's
happening with Ron people are Whispering
into Ron's ear every single day you're
the guy
you're the guy
yeah you can really do it you're the guy
so the the grifter glass the the
strategists who get paid whether they
win or lose and mostly they lose on our
side are saying yeah I'll be your
campaign manager let me be your your
bundler point man you can do it Ron
you're the man so basically grifter
class let me interrupt you real quick
the grifter class because a lot of
people who are listening may not
understand that there are political
consultants and other people the
Strategic the time the campaign will
make millions of dollars for themselves
and millions and millions of dollars
whether they win or lose that's correct
you go into the arena you get stabbed
and torn up by a lion right it doesn't
matter here's my invoice so there's
these guys when it comes to the field
right now I really think Ron believes
that he can win which is amazing he's 40
points down and he thinks he can win and
and I like him I preface I like him
Vivek I think Vivek Vivek is like a
little bit like the Elon Musk I got a
new toy it's politics it's fun and he
wants to save America he's an uh I think
he's a son of him immigrants yeah he's a
son of immigrants he loves America of
effective of all the people I'd like to
see Vivek in the Trump Administration to
have the Jared role he should be the
innovator economic growth you know all
that stuff he should be doing all that
stuff for the president
yeah a True Believer in America but I
also think having interviewed him on my
show he really thinks he can be
president would be fine it's fine but in
the to go back to your saying being
insulated with people who are all about
the Maga agenda do you think Vivek Rama
Swami he isn't is really on that same
page as Trump because he's been pretty
critical of trump don't you think no I I
it depends what you mean on the page
with in terms of loving America and
believing America is great 100 does he
agree with everything president Trump
says why would he but if he's going to
have the Jared role doesn't he happen
but doesn't he have to be look at
look at cap you know team of uh Ryan or
what you're saying I don't think so yeah
you don't think what I agree I don't
think he does because this is a form of
shown strength it's like yeah it's like
Barnes being recruited by Kobe it's like
uh Ron Artest you're not disrespecting
but I'm not afraid of you right that is
a good sign to want to have somebody
like that part of your team it's how
Kamala got her job although her job was
a little bit more disrespectful he
doesn't like Yes Man president Trump
does not like yes man so so so let's
let's stay on this you talk about Ron
okay who's in his ear okay uh last
weekend we were at not last weekend
whatever last Thursday or something we
spend a few hours with him at the
governor's mansion just ourselves 10 15
other people were invited to uh uh to
kind of watch how he is and what he says
and the approach and all this other
stuff and I've been very critical of the
governor I I I I think he's done a
phenomenal job for the state but I think
his marketing team absolutely sucks and
they need to be fired and found a new
person and some people think that could
be a relative but I think the market
team needs help so now that's a
different story yeah
one I'll start off by just asking you an
open-ended question about him as a
candidate on who's in his ear is he
making the right job running today
should he not be running should he be
running and what's the best case or the
worst case scenario here at the end of
this election 2024 for specifically
Governor Ron DeSantis so I I somebody
sent me a load of bumper stickers that
are in my green room at my studio that
say 2024 uh Trump DeSantis I said that
for months for months Trump the
scientist if he's smart politically if
he's a strategic thinker which I don't
think he is
he comes in as Veep and then he or a
member of the cabinet whatever and then
he slides seamlessly into the top slot
for 2028 that's not happening now number
one this weird thing that he hasn't
declared dude you changed the
constitution of Florida so you can run
as an incumbent Governor what the hell
are you waiting for and then after the
brag announcement and the indictment
he's toast oh two things the flip-flop
on Ukraine and then the brag indictment
this guy this guy's not ready for prime
time what he did on that press
conference the Monday after the
indictment leaked was Despicable as a
former former Jack in the Navy to say
I'm not gonna get involved in these
things dude he's a resident of Florida
you are involved whether you like it or
not and not once but twice to make the I
don't know about harsh money for porn
stars your child that that's we saw the
real Ron DeSantis on that Monday presser
you said that not once but twice
of a president who actually made you
Governor let's be clear he was like 12
points behind the other guy in the
primary president Trump Taps him and
he's number one and why is he popular
it's like you know everybody loves
Austin Powers what is Dr Ron DeSantis
he's the mini me to president Trump I'm
sorry
I'm sorry
what he's doing in here is trumpian
whether it's taking on the transgender
the Dei open for business I mean this
this is a little version of President
Trump in Florida
and then you flip-flop on Ukraine not
ready for prime time sorry do you think
it's leadership do you think it's policy
do you think marketing character tell me
what do you mean by takara's character
he doesn't have
I I can't I can't explain it better
Saturday Saturday night it leaks yes
that the man who campaigned on I will
put Trump in prison who got a million
dollars from George Soros and then
becomes the D.A in Manhattan that man is
going to charge president Trump with 34
total garbage out of date misdemeanors
magically turned into felonies and on
Monday you have a press conference about
something and the reporter says what's
your reaction to the news of the
indictment to the 45th president well I
don't know about hush money for porn
stars and let me repeat that again and
I'm going to concentrate on Florida so
I'm not going to talk about this you're
a former military prosecutor you're a
former Jag you don't have opinion on
this that the 45th president after the
Mar-A-Lago raid is now facing the
Manhattan D.A oh and by the way he's a
resident of the state you're governor of
and he helped make you Governor you're a
child run you're a child you're like in
high school you're like in the click and
I think I came she's ugly it's like come
on grow up so which part of this
character do you think failed him there
you've got Integrity
loyalty what part of the character honor
honor it's a lack of Honor it's a lack
of Honor so self-interested Pride leads
him to a lack of Honor surely childish
attitude to questions of Honor I mean
sorry I don't care who you are you
shouldn't have to be a former prosecutor
but to say that what has happened
against this man is not political
persecution
you're not a good person to say that
this man's home was raided his wife's
wardrobes were turned over by armed
agents of the federal government despite
the fact that his home is protected by
the Secret Service and you have nothing
to say about that nothing to say about
that that's a lack of Honor
well he's expected to declare this week
well it's supposed to be it was supposed
to be yesterday I mean how many times
have we heard next Monday Ron's
declaring what's he waiting for fair
enough but this is supposed to be the
week and
for all intents and purposes I'm very
confident he is going to be declaring
any day now Okay so
passes
I get it don't do it don't do it but
he's gonna do it I respect your opinion
here but he's gonna do it and Casey
DeSantis is very closely aligned with
helping him run this
um
do not like his chances whatsoever you
see that Republican Mega donors are
basically now running his Direction he's
basically well not just the Republican
Mega donors I mean this is this is the
stuff that people really need to wake up
to and you know get red pilled Ken
Griffin
Citadel Capital Obama bundler is funding
him can we just repeat that sentence for
everybody who missed it Obama bundler
billionaire Ken Griffin is funding Ron
DeSantis you also see people like Peter
Thiel potentially even Elon but think
about this why isn't Obama bundler Obama
bundler even being allowed to give him a
dollar
this is this is creepy this is weird
right why would he not be allowed to
give this hand this money well is he
Maga or is he is he is he is he deep
State Obama buddy I'll take whoever
whoever's money is he America First is
it on Capital based in Illinois so
potentially there's a relationship there
he's a Senator of Illinois
I go back to my primary statement here
America is divided by those who love
America and those who hate it this guy
hates America who hates America Ken
Griffin yeah totally and Ken Griffin
who's made deals hates America uh you
know George Soros is Rich right yeah
we're not saying I mean being rich
doesn't mean you love him I hear you but
you're saying that Ken Griffin George
Soros if you're bundling for the man who
who rode on the I will fundamentally
trans transform America yeah if you're a
former bundler for the guy who said I
hate America so much I'm gonna change it
until you can't recognize it whose wife
on inauguration day says this is the
first time in my life I'm proud of
America yeah yes Michelle Obama
yeah it's a problem these are the things
that you have to pick up on you can't
can't smooth these over I'm trying I'm
trying to unpack everything you just
said so number one uh uh the question
was asked of Giuliani or for him running
as a VP apparently he cannot because
they're both residents of the State of
Florida so apparently you can't Julian
Rudy Giuliani regarding regarding the
Santa's running would Trump apparently
he can't because they're both residents
one of them has to move out that's the
that's the part one of them has to move
out so that's enough of course if they
decided that one can go to New York
right and that's not going to be hard to
do so that's one number two in regards
to his comments right after uh what
happened at Mar-A-Lago uh can I think
about it from a competitive standpoint a
moment of personal interest knowing the
guy that's in the way of your lifelong
dream becoming a reality just got you
know indicted and they went to his place
and this is pretty much a short shot for
you to become a president and you're
excited about it so let me just you know
capitalize on this yes does that show a
quality of selfishness that the guy that
helped you get there now you're not
defending him okay fair that's a very
fair assessment on what you're saying uh
you know what happens next with his
announcement him delaying it I don't
understand that part it's a [__] show to
me you come out with your book four
months ago yeah when you come out with a
book that book is only a book written
for election to run for office nobody
wrote the timing The Playbook has always
been the same write the book launch it
right go out there talking about it so
people can read your book and say okay
this is what this guy's running on fine
I like him I don't like him I didn't
know that this was cool and by the way I
actually think it's a great book I think
he missed the mark with the book I read
the book I thought he edified Trump
multiple multiple times in the book this
would have been a very good opportunity
but maybe somebody said it's not that
big of a book just do a couple different
things here and there and then go out
then you lose a Megan Kelly who doesn't
like a trump that calls you out for not
agreeing to go on her show and talk to
other people like us that it's gonna
move your book you don't want to do that
okay that's that's not a good look now
on the flip side for you saying what you
said about his mishaps the people that
are not Trump people could say are you
kidding me do you want me to talk about
the 15 mishaps with what the president
said and what he did in his past and
this and this and that that's going to
be their argument that so I think that
kind of cancels each other out the
question then becomes okay so I asked
this question of uh uh uh clay Travis
and Buck Sexton okay they're here and I
said I said you guys sound like a
spokesperson for the sentence that's
what you sound like because they were
both very much uh good guys but they're
both not necessarily siding with Trump
they're citing more with the sentence
great but here's the question that I
asked it was kind of interesting by the
way because you know where I'm going to
go with this what they said
in Isis from Tulsi for your thoughts
here how much uh power does the right
person giving you money and endorsing
you have in a presidential election how
much power influence does that have
I I thank the good Lord I've never been
in the room where you know a donor or a
rep of a donor has said to somebody I
know you know we did give you a million
bucks last year what are you gonna do
for us now that's how DC works right the
lobby the lobbying functions on that
basis yes right so Pfizer gives you X
and then the guy help from Pfizer helps
you write the the legislation that goes
to the Senate aid office and then that
gets chewed around and put into the
legislation so that that's politics no
doubt about that but you're spot on with
that of course not I mean that's that's
why lobbying exists yeah but this is
where I'm going with that I'm asking
like okay the endorsement the power of
me being Schwartzman saying I got the
Santas we're going with the Santos right
Citadel we're going with the center
steel going with the Sand by the way
Schwartzman is not 100 confirmed because
they came out so nobody fully knows it I
think we'll find that next three to six
months but let's say a must comes out
and says I don't think we should have a
president above the age of 69. okay
seven years old Rogan hey you know
DeSantis more than Trump right some of
these guys how much influence today with
the social you're seeing Trump being on
elk boys and you know 10 million views
and this is younger audience that you're
appealing to that you go into places
like that how much influence do the
right uh endorsements have in a
presidential election like a musk said
I'm team DeSantis a hundred percent
right and let's just say he gave I don't
know let's pick a number 50 million 100
million dollars okay to a pack and I'm
going to santis or I'm going Trump Vice
how much influence does a person like
that have if I could answer that I I
would not be sitting here I would be you
know flying my helicopter around
Tropical Islands with my kids you know
that that is the question is that a
desire we can get you a helicopter let's
let's do that can we scale helicopter
tropical faster we're gonna do that done
all right there are several Bahamas 30
minutes away we could fly here let's do
it
um that you know how much is an
endorsement worth it I watched all of
your Tulsi interview and I think she
said the the right answer depends upon
who's doing the endorsing let's say and
who the candidate is let's say musk and
Trump or DeSantis
his
so here's my res response I think 24
2024 is going to be a lot like Carter
versus Reagan because it's going to boil
down to one question uh you bet this is
what Reagan asked the American people
are you better off than you were four
years ago
it's not about anybody else Richard
Barris is the only pulse that I trust in
America Rich was on my show last week
and he said the only question it's not
it's not about DeSantis it's not about
anybody else it's not about Kamala it's
about
Biden versus Trump that's the next
election that's the only question that's
the only question people have in their
mind do you think Trump should debate
the other guys on the Republican side
you know what one of the things I'm very
grateful to president Trump for apart
from you know hiring me is do you
remember how fun politics was he made
fun politics fun again those primaries
were awesome I mean I would love to see
30 people on the primary debate stage
it's like you know WWF let's do it bring
it everybody and you think he would
welcome that yeah he loves that stuff
that's the part I agree with because a
lot of people are saying the fact that
Trump's not going to do you know the
debates and all that I think he's
looking forward to it because for him
you ever seen him being roasted you know
what is that when they do the roast and
Snoop gets up there and all these guys
are roasting him and yeah the company
said yeah yeah and he just sits there
and he takes it you know most people
they're not brave enough to be roasted I
actually think he is a roaster and I
think a natural roaster I think he can't
wait to roast all these guys on the
right with the debate but going back to
the question yeah going back to the
question you still haven't answered it
no because I I don't think I I it's your
opinion I'm not looking for a factual
statement I would be super excited if
Elon said yeah Trump's the guy but I
don't think it really makes a difference
I I don't think people walk in to The
Ballot Box and say yeah I'm voting for
wrong but I agree but no but I don't
disagree but here's the question I don't
disagree if anybody endorses Trump
meaning
the Trump vote no one cares if you
endorse him right do you understand what
I'm saying but what but what matters is
to the scientists oh this is Santa so if
a mosque says I'm the scientist and
here's 50 100 million bucks how big
because politics has become since since
brexit Trump Modi Urban and Maloney
politics has been boiled down to one
thing and one thing alone authenticity
it really that doesn't it really doesn't
matter money do you know how much money
Hillary spent against us we spent eight
hundred thousand dollars
a 800 million million dollars legally
what we know of Legally she spent 1.4
billion
are you calling Biden the most authentic
president of all time no no I'm saying
they stole the election
well that's it that that's another thing
there sorry sorry YouTube uh there were
issues with that election
yeah I think by the way and and you just
so you know you saying that he said that
at the Town Hall and it sounds like
that's gonna be a one of the talking
points over the next 17 months well this
when people say get over it don't talk
about it it's like that's what the left
wants you to say do you understand they
want you not to talk about the life of
the approach for me Sebastian would be
to follow let me tell you what's one of
my biggest concerns when it comes down
to election yeah specific to election uh
I I think election fraud has been going
on for a long time and I think election
fraud is something that they've gotten
better and better and better at but I
also think election fraud we can figure
out a way to make it oh yeah this
electronic things yeah I think I think I
love it what I'm saying is what I'm
saying is the final one
if he campaigns on that I'm all for I'm
going to be saying it off the top of my
lungs if it's hey what if we can do the
following we have blockchain technology
we have this we have that do you
remember that one time he got up and he
showed the PowerPoint uh uh with the
pictures that was being shown on a uh uh
uh uh it was a regular conversation he
was getting was showing bullet points
here's what we're going to do with covet
and then went to the next slide and the
next slide and the next slide what if
they got up and he showed technology and
says look here's what's available today
for elections due to blockchain
technology this is what we can do to
make sure all of your votes count and
quite frankly some of you guys have a
busy schedule to the people on the left
that don't have the time to go vote
guess what no problem to the people that
are on the military that are overseas no
problem here's what blockchain
technology will do and we have three
different options of companies to use if
I get elected what we're going to do is
we're going to make this thing so easy
and clear and honest that everybody
knows your account your vote's going to
get elected we can see it you can go
look at it I think that is a campaign
mess that's going to get people to say I
want honest and fair yeah voting I'm for
it right rather than pulling the Hillary
Clinton one of well let me tell you you
know uh you know Russia this yeah I just
I just don't think that's attractive to
people that are capitalists and
dependent doers we we I raise my kids to
not be helpless I raise my kids to be
we're gonna go beat these guys no matter
what if they're doing this get tougher
get stronger get bigger but if we expose
them from this standpoint then the left
has to argue what how unfair and racist
it is to get people that don't have IDs
but wait a minute I need an ID to buy
this so then they're going to lose that
argument that's all I'm saying no I like
it and it's very trumpian to say we're
going to fix it and here's crazy that is
that's the problem there's a problem
though it's not his job right the US
Constitution is clear the States run
elections he can say the states should
use blockchain and the state house
should buy this but the president has no
power to do but you know what he can't
say he can say the states that decide to
use blockchain we're gonna give X XYZ to
contribute and support with the
technology and we're going to do that
totally I think that can be said yeah I
like it to me that is similar messaging
on what you're saying so hey if you
think there was fraud here's what we can
do here's a way to solve it boom so okay
so let's go back to Casey descent
someone read a story I just want to hear
your thoughts on this if you have any
opinions on it at all so uh what page is
it on there it is okay so Casey and
Ronda santis okay uh the greatest asset
and his greatest liability this is a
political article that's written uh let
me go to page eight
um
all right here we go
the Casey DeSantis problem his greatest
asset and his greatest liability
political May 19. Casey DeSantis wife
Aranda sent his significant figure in
his political career and often seen as
his greatest asset she's charismatic
telegenic and has a policy portfolio of
Rambo she's a beast in smaller City I
couldn't even believe how powerful she
was unlike run unbelievable how she was
in a smaller setting however some view
Casey has both an important advisor and
a political liability she's heavily
involved in decision making leading to a
small inner circle around Ron suggests
she is hesitant to seed power and can be
vindictive leading to conflict with
staff and strategic mistakes now again
this could be a hit piece they're going
after her the truth who knows the role
of Casey descent is a matter of concern
and debate for many with some believing
she humanizes and enhances Ron's image
While others worry about her influence
and the need for a more professional
team around him what are your thoughts
about Casey well first things first uh I
I'm kind of I saw the rundown in the
green room and I saw this article was in
there I was a little bit uncomfortable
because I think wives are
um
the outer bounds they came after my wife
she was a presidential appointee in the
DHS but she wasn't a public figure when
they came after her The Daily Beast all
these scumbags and half po that that's
the easiest way to piss me off
um if you're not a public figure they're
sacred your partner your spouse is
sacred and the only interaction I've had
with her and I want to put this on the
record because I haven't talked about it
anywhere else is when I found out about
her cancer about a year ago on my show
we got like three and a half million
listeners and I'm you know I'm Catholic
I believe I said would you just take a
moment dear friends and just say a
prayer for for Casey and and for the
DeSantis family and I I did it because
you know I saw the news and I thought
let's you know use this power of Prayer
about a month later I get a letter from
the office of the first lady of Florida
and it's her thanking me I've never
received anything I mean apart from
present sending me stuff which is fine
it's my old boss I've never received
something from a public figure of that
ilk just thank me for something
so so I'm not going to qualify her
politically I will say one thing he does
need somebody to humanize him because he
he is not you know you've met him right
the guy is not warm and fuzzy I mean he
knows how to slam down the media and
it's beautiful to watch but he's not a
people person he's not a people person
so uh I appreciate that and and my
feeling about her is the same way
however I have a big however I'll be the
bad guy you can meet a nice guy so
and I haven't heard anything bad about
her but who wrote where was that piece
this is political oh but but it's but
it's also coming from uh a few others as
well I mean it's not it's not just that
that's talking about them Insider said a
few things which doesn't say much about
Insider but here's the part for me I
come from a different angle you ever
seen the movie Air the recent movie with
uh you're not a basketball guy so this
movie The Story of Michael Jordan how
Nike landed him Etc et cetera there's a
scene with son of a car you that's
preparing Michael Jordan for the fall to
say listen yes you're going to win
championships yes you're going to win
MVPs you're going to do all this stuff
great but guess what they're going to
come after you and for me there's
different types of wives meaning ivani
am I saying uh Melania is the kind of a
wife a first lady to me that's kind of
like listen I support you I'll go do the
shaking hands all this stuff but I'm not
going to be Michelle Obama it's you make
sense like this is your job I got Baron
as my job and I'm going to be this but
do not get me involved and guess what my
view president Donald Trump saying
you're totally fine babe do what you got
to do I got this that's kind of how I
view that okay uh for me Barack uh if
you bring Michelle in and Michelle's
also throwing punches you gotta if we
get into a fight let's just say me and
my wife a woman comes and a husband and
wife are fighting us
if he's swinging and if my wife swings
her at her she swings back I'm not going
to be surprised that's what her job is
let's just say but if my wife is like
listen let's step aside let's have our
husbands kind of do their thing that's
what I see but Casey is a also a fighter
so but is she doing that fighting
publicly like Michelle I don't think no
no I don't see her as Michelle at all I
don't see her as Michelle but I think
she's part of the campaign the whole
thing Casey and Ron DeSantis have such a
close partnership they've morphed into a
singular entity people called the de
santai right not the DeSantis political
there's a part of this that if you play
to this card I do believe they have to
be ready that people are going to come
after her because she is one of those oh
no they have they have to be ready so I
just want to make sure it's not going to
be like no not fair what they're doing
no expect the darkest of the waist to
approach you yeah and to me uh if the
approach is kind of like it's unfair
what they're doing it's got to be more
totally get it if we're choosing to have
that highest job in office in America
this comes with the territory we're
totally okay with that right that to me
is a little bit more of a you know
respect but I gotta tell you I've been a
lot of small group settings and I've
seen a lot of wives that are super
powered on a cup power couple power
she is very very solid and what I mean
by solid Charisma charm likability
incredible Communicator smart
intelligent True Believer mannerisms
respecting husband edifying him getting
out of the way not the shadow doesn't
need the Limelight doesn't even take the
the shots that Michelle would take out
Obama I don't know if you know what
shots I'm talking about sometimes she
kind of undermines him zero all of that
she's a she's a dime in the way of a
first lady so I think that is going to
be a big part for him you made a common
tour when you said you kind of got to be
out there more I don't know how much of
a role she's going to be playing I think
if she does play a role
um she's a she's a very strong uh uh
she's a very strong a strength of his if
it's used okay let's see what's gonna
happen I'll just add one thing uh when
we did have a brief conversation I was I
told her to her face I said I was very
impressed with how you handled yourself
and she was almost like you think so
yeah you think I should talk this much I
was like
keep doing that what you're doing it was
very very impressive super impressive
maybe she should be out there more I I
think so I and by the way I one million
percent think so again I have no clue
who is their marketing manner
oh my God his influences on Twitter I
know These Guys these were friends of
mine they are just so
unprofessional it's shocking well he's
about to join the big leagues right now
what I mean try right well correct he's
going to be announcing and I think I'm
sort of half joking but I'm actually
being honest I think he needs to hire
like the queer eye for the straight guys
makeover team and and realize we are now
going against yeah whether you like him
or not maybe one of the Bros
can you imagine Ron DeSantis announces
his marketing manager Dylan Mulvaney
zero you have to become the most
relevant person
uh VP of marketing right but he is going
against whether you like him or not one
of the most brilliant marketers totally
ever with Donald Trump and whether it's
he can do the policy thing all day long
that's not going to move the needle he
needs to he's the go to learn the
marketing strategy he's to go to there's
nobody better that's nobody he's the god
of Mark we still talk about those
nicknames we still talk about Little
Marco we still talk about you know
crooked Hillary we still talk about them
seven years later he is
Ted Cruz's wife is still very ugly in
the face by the way uh Epstein are you
following the story with gates at all I
am I'm like not interested I mean this
whole gate is like a nerd with too much
money and maybe he ran around with you
know girls who were too young it's like
seriously I want to see the list I want
to see the list I don't care about but I
want to see the John's list okay so
here's the question do you think that is
I asked this question on Twitter the
other day if you want to pull this up I
did a poll and I said which of these
four things would you want the 2024
candidate to talk about I don't know if
you saw this or not the four issues and
then I said I saw your thing about uh
Biden economy versus Trump economy now
that was as a sexist I liked that that
was good that's sexist credit goes to
our guy from uh uh uh uh Raul anyways
put this up there zoom in a little bit
wow so okay exactly so which issues
matter to you the most in 2020 and I
said for any other issues below that's
interesting investigate it's 20 000
votes investigate the Wuhan lab lowest
and and by the way that's a big part of
his play 39 border immigration 33.
nobody can can do what he doesn't no
because when he says it'll land in 24
hours it will agree and nobody else
nobody can say I totally agree but the
Epstein list do you think that is
something that people are interested in
you think that's a that's enough of my
list for camp for some other campaign
behind or not really I think these are
your followers right these are these are
your listeners right these are people
who are interested um I don't I don't
think that is look you have to
understand everybody in this room is a
freak right because we're into politics
most Americans are not into politics
they want to make the car payment at the
end of the month and make sure the kid
is a new pair of sneakers for the new
semester right
um Epstein for most Americans like who
what I'm not sure I'm not sure it's
important because we need to know who
went to that Island we need to know I
don't think it's a campaign issue it's
going to be the board look who said it
it's the economy stupid it's going to be
the economy and the border and those two
things James Carville yeah right Clinton
right Clinton uh Bush
um yeah but that's it the Russia thing
is fascinating 38.8 interesting it's not
even I mean it's not even a close thing
in the top two no no and people how
quickly they're overcovered I am shell
shocked that investigate Wuhan lab is
not higher
and assume our audience like assume even
I thought our audience would have been
higher than 7.6 percent but even our
audience is saying nah listen man I'm
over we got bigger things it just shows
two years later boom done with that
let's go what's going on America moves
on how quickly America moves on at this
pace we're going to be we're in uh uh
Kanye West uh Year's shoes
it's coming soon guys
since president Trump's going to walk up
to it maybe the scientists will to speak
to that if you know we're looking
forward now backwards doesn't that give
sort of uh testimony to stop doing the
election denial thing because people are
over it isn't that a case right there I
don't know partially but but I'm telling
you for me I made a video 11 years ago
10 years ago on how I would change
voting I'm going to text it to you for
you to watch it's it's not a private
video it's not a public video how to
change the voting system right
to me I don't like our system on the way
we vote I don't trust it I'm not
comfortable with it I don't even like
the way it's set up for for the
structure of it so I think that is
something I would be talking about if
I'm campaigning but I'm not I'm just the
guy that's running businesses completely
different ballgame we're playing here
have you seen kill chain kill chain the
documentary
you need to watch kill chain kill chain
was made by the Democrats before the
2016 election and it's got Senator
Warren and all these people and it is an
hour and a half on how you can hack our
elections and how the biggest threat to
America is hacked elections you can't
find it's very hard to find now watch
kill chain kill chain they go to eBay
they buy Dominion computer yeah they
take it to a cyber hacking conference
within 30 minutes the machine is hacked
I mean this you're allowed to talk about
it until a certain point when you're not
allowed to talk about it but what you
said earlier is correct they've been
doing this for 60 years I mean think
about we're in America the only nation
on the planet that put men on the moon
six times and we make jokes about
Philadelphia Chicago and Baltimore
stealing elections we make jokes about
it yeah you don't need you know
high-tech to do this if you've been
doing it for 60 years but it is a
problem that needs to be fixed the idea
that India can have voter ID
India more than a billion people Mexico
with a civil war with an Insurgency with
the cartels has voter ID and we don't
that's insane by the way what you just
did right there I would have somebody on
his team create a 10 slide PowerPoint
the next time he's speaking and you know
how he goes through a speech and just
show this did you know India has voter
ID did you know because American people
are going to say wait Mexico is more
advanced than us India is more advanced
how come we don't have this right we
should have this as well that's what
gets people thinking now next story I
want to get into is about what NAACP
just announced I don't know if you saw
that or not the travel ban yes hate
inspired leadership NAACP joins other
other groups and warning against travel
to Florida this is a Miami Herald story
from yesterday the oldest civil group
Civil Rights group in the U.S has issued
a travel advisory urging travelers to
reconsider visiting Florida due to the
states openly hostile leadership
significantly specific quickly citing
Governor Ron DeSantis attempts to ban
books
about race and lgbtq identities in his
opposition to diversity and inclusion
programs in colleges NAACP Derek Johnson
president argues that the refusal to
teach an accurate representation of
channel of the challenges faced by
African Americans as a disservice to
students and a neglect of Duty other
civil rights organizations such as lulac
and equality Florida have also shoot
Travel warnings for Florida citing
concerns over the Santa's Crackdown of
immigration and the potential risks to
health safety and freedom however
tourism in Florida remain strong with
record numbers of visitors and local
leaders emphasized their City's
commitment to diversity inclusion by the
way I wouldn't even be surprised if the
NAACP isn't staying at Miami for uh
summer time
Jesse Waters did a thing on his show
last night yeah that chairwoman just
posted from Twitter her holiday her
vacation in Florida exactly right these
are politically motivated totally this
is no this is a political boy caught
that has no teeth whatsoever Budweiser
is down by by some estimates 28 thanks
to the Bud Light boycott which has been
very effective and very welcomed by
Coors and competitors on one hand on the
other hand you look at the diversity in
Florida you look at diversity at the
beaches someone didn't get the memo that
you were supposed to boycott and maybe
go to some other place
how about Chicago why don't we boycott
you know Chicago 22 people shot last
weekend and I can guarantee you that
most of those are black Americans so why
aren't we boycotting Chicago or
Baltimore yeah the average weekend on
Chicago is 10 people killed and 50 shot
the average weekend but the NAACP
straight back lives matter doesn't care
about the people being killed in Chicago
it's just hypocrisy yeah I don't think
this travel ban is doing anything or
this travel warning is doing anything to
mitigate people from traveling to
Florida whether it's the Panhandle
whether they're going to Disney World in
Orlando where they're coming to South
Beach in Miami people are coming
nobody's like you know that vacation
we've been working on for the last two
months for the summer let's go yeah
there's the NAACP made this warning but
they're like dude we're going to party
stop it yeah you say that but I
literally had a guest that's scheduled
for your podcast that sent an email
yesterday hey bro I want to confirm it's
safe for me and my family to travel
there still I'm seeing this over the
internet and news I'm coming with my
girlfriend and our two sons is it safe
or should we reschedule and then they
included an Instagram post to the naac
don't say the name can you text me the
name who it is by the way yes can you
text me and meanwhile show the show the
meme I just sent you a guy sent me this
I thought it was that's wild something
very interesting uh uh uh to think about
tulsi's Texan right now but can you can
you post this real quick uh uh which
which makes you think and by the way
whether you like this meme or nod there
is a lot of truth behind this meme uh
here's what the meme is dumb I don't
know if you've seen this one uh take a
look at this Adam what's tall suit
texting
white victim nobody cares black is
silent black victim nobody cares black
is silent white victim nobody cares
white is selling black victim
people lose their minds there's your
news there's your mainstream media uh
narrative that's the narrative that they
will support that's Neely that's that's
the filter for the stories right
yeah no but this is this is what makes
and by the way uh didn't they just have
a 25 000 Haitians had an event here
happy doing an event in Florida right
you look at the crime on what's going on
you look at how many people are moving
here to Florida
statistically that argument loses a lot
of weight when they say you got to be
careful moving to Florida I love it how
people can say things like that but data
argues completely the other way than you
do this is what happened with Newsome
Newsome talked about how terrible
Florida is more people the more he talks
[__] about Florida the more people from
California wanted to move to Florida and
it's not slowing down and by the way
this is due to a great Governor a guy
named Ron DeSantis thanks to Donald
Trump yeah
freaking Newsome
Newsome the green governor with a half a
barrel of oil in his hair yeah hey let's
let's talk about this uh uh uh let's
talk about this other story I'm trying
to see which one to go through let's go
through this one here page 15 uh a
meeting I don't know if you were invited
to this meeting or not your accent says
yes but your value says no a secretive
annual meeting attended by the world's
Elite has AI top of the agenda CNBC
story open AIC CEO Sam Altman joins Tech
leaders and political heavyweights at
the selective annual Bilderberg meeting
in Lisbon Portugal they're they're
public about it now it's no longer
Builders yeah uh the meetings agenda
places a strong emphasis on artificial
intelligence and includes a discussion
on topics such as the banking system
China energy transition Europe fiscal
challenges in the industrial policy and
trade nato-russia transitional threats
Ukraine and U.S leadership the three-day
event attended by approximately 130
participants from 23 different countries
maintains which prevent the disclosure
of speakers
uh uh identities and affiliations the
clandestine nature of the meeting has
given rise to conspiracy theories uh but
organizers state that it facilitates
open and unrestricted discussions the
Bilderberg meeting established in 1954
aims to promote dialogue between Europe
and North America than these participate
as individuals rather than an official
capacity when a meeting like this
happened what do you think about this is
there anything behind it is it uh the
conspiracy theories do they have
anything right about this or is it just
guys coming together together to talk
about the future threats look I I love
conspiracy theories I'm actually
launching a new TV show that's expressly
about them but I like them as
entertainment there's a reason they're
called theories and not conspiracy facts
they've been is this news that rich
people who are powerful hang out with
each other and think they can run the
world no I mean go back to Bretton Woods
go back in time to any Elite that has
power that has money they think that
they can shape the future the
Rothschilds Bohemian Grove San Francisco
on and on and on and on medicis this
this yeah this isn't new back to
Machiavelli the prince you you name it
when it comes to AI you know I'm not I'm
not a wonk okay uh I'm not a geek I just
don't buy this you know Skynet is across
the Horizon we're about to be the the
idea that we can't just pull the plug at
some point on this stuff when it gets
too scary trying to get a reference very
good yeah yeah I mean you know the idea
that it helps you write your college
essays okay that's really exciting I
mean okay but the idea that this is some
threat to humanity I'm open to uh here
people who are building this stuff tell
me yes this is the greatest threat to
humanity but while we've got six million
people crossing the border illegally 110
000 people dying from fentanyl China
re-militarizing Russia with nuclear
weapons invading other people's
countries you know I'm not going to get
too excited about this stuff Tom
well I I think this has been going on
for a long time and you know you go back
to Rothschilds in the banking and you
know I I think that
when groups of people like this get
together it draws a lot of fire and a
lot of there's a lot of magnetism with
what's going on there uh and and I think
what's what's also going on is you've
got the purveyors of AI trying to get
the political Elite to calm down about
AI you have to remember what's going on
here there's a lot of money to be made
in these in these companies and a lot of
investment it's billions of dollars have
already been invested in AI so you have
Sam Altman open AI CEO and and um
y combinator frame incubator you know
saying Easy Does It Easy Does It yeah
there could be some things here but easy
does it meanwhile what they don't want
you this is a classic thing where I
think the purveyors of AI the inventors
and those operating companies and
Investments really don't want the
governments to come in and regulate it I
think this is this is let me ask a
question in different ways so either one
of you guys if you got an invitation to
go to the Builder to build a Bilderberg
meeting would you go to it if it's not a
big I hate these people why would I go
okay so yeah I know these are to go to
zero but they want to get your
perspective your point of view okay I
don't care these people the kind of a
diplomat are you I'm not a diplomat you
know what the only other drawback was
three jobs I do the next Administration
what's that I do National Security
advisor I'd run Personnel you know the
only third one for shits and greens
what's that I'd be ambassador to the UN
so I could walk in there and the whole
building would catch a flame that's it
diplomacy no forget about it this is
America it's about leadership it's about
being the greatest nation on God's green
earth these people hate the people so
the people that attention they hate the
people they do of course they hate the
people they chose the wrong person in in
2016. they chose the wrong box on the
brexit vote they chose the wrong person
in Hungary they hate the choice of the
people why is populism a dirty word
think about that for a second populism
is a dirty word
excuse me it the thing you're doing is
popular with the most people
that tells you everything you need to
know when the left made populism a
pejorative you realize what they think
of the average person I traveled with
President Trump on Air Force One to
Youngstown Ohio now Youngstown is deep
Rust Belt okay we got off Air Force One
at a military base no press no nothing
he got into the Beast we had about a 20
minute ride to the stadium okay on the
left hand side all we saw was shuttered
closed steel mill you know broken glass
broken windows on on the other side of
the road people modestly dressed with
their children on the side of the road
waving a little stars and stripes we get
to the stadium the boss is in the back
with the VIPs I decide to go into the
pit take selfies with people I'd
realized
that these are all Democrats their dads
were Democrats their grandparents worked
in the mill when he came out on stage
with Melania he couldn't give a speech
for minutes because they were screaming
USA USA USA those are the people the
bilderbergers hate
the people who built America by the
sweat of their brow I have no interest
hanging out with those people got it I
was gonna say they they were telling us
there's an invitation for you go you go
I was trying to get you I'll do the
helicopter right they have no interest
for you I'll do that now you're saying
that no so you just heard his answer the
answer is no and I'll counter that
Sebastian I agree with you and about
[Music]
94.625 of what you just said I agree
with Trader very specific numbers yep
but I would go you I would go and if
they're going to invite the Trojan Horse
to their con Fab I'm going would you
touch the Trojan Horse never let's do it
touch it okay Ukraine Russia you briefed
a lot of o5s06s and one Stars
um
this is a question from a lot of
different people that get asked and you
hear the answer how can you not see what
Russia is doing how can you not see what
Ukraine is doing how can I not see the
fact that there's ties between Biden and
Ukraine do you not remember what he said
publicly if you don't do this and then
I'll do this how can you not see all
this stuff and then hey F-16 yeah maybe
we'll let him train and then if somebody
else gives them we're not going to get
in the way are you saying you're not
going to give them f-16s we may we don't
know right now I can't answer that so
what is your thoughts on what's going on
over there uh I wrote a piece on my sub
stack as soon as the war came out you
can check it I haven't changed my
opinion then I remember the good old
days when conservatives hated KGB
Colonels and thought Russia invading
other countries was bad I remember those
days the idea today that oh he's a
champion of the West and he's a
Christian you mean the same guy who
persecuted Christians when he was a
uniform wearing member of the KGB what
about the bio Labs oh who built the bio
Labs the Soviet Union built the bio Labs
that's interesting and then the question
that well we shouldn't help them because
Ukraine's corrupt huh that's the dumbest
one is DC corrupt do you think Biden's
corrupt if you do does that mean China
can just invade and roll their tanks
down Pennsylvania Avenue this is wrong
the simplest way to understand it
corruption up the Yazoo or not is this
this man is a bully
He's a Bully who said for 20 years since
he became president he's been giving
lectures how Ukraine how Poland how the
Baltic states are illegitimate have no
right to exist as independent states go
back to school go back to when you're 10
year old
what happens to the bully if he doesn't
get challenged
what happens he keeps on bullying when
does he stop bullying when you give the
bastard a bloody nose we're hoping the
ukrainians give this guy a bloody nose
and to the last thing about this Tucker
Carlson kind of who cares about the
world pull down the shutters on the
Pacific and the Atlantic screw them all
if 1776 means something to you as an
American let me remind you that without
the French the Dutch and the Spanish
this would still be part of the British
Empire period end of story if the French
hadn't blockaded the British if the
Dutch and the Spanish hadn't bankrolled
Washington meaning General Washington
we never would have won this is their
1776. so if it means something to you if
our revolutionary will mean something us
helping other people fight their 1776 uh
it should mean something to you as well
so no apologies to people I've pissed
off Ukraine has a right to be
independent the Kremlin are a bunch of
bastards uh and we should help them
fight for themselves not deploy the 82nd
Airborne I'm not interested in Dumb Wars
and us fighting other people's Wars they
should fight their Wars and we should
help them end of story how much heat do
you catch from having this opinion I
mean this man alive you're born in
Hungary you understand Soviet communism
you understand Russia I'd go on Banner's
show every week this is not popular with
with the the War Room Hobbits and even
with Steve but now if you if you're in
the Trump Administration and you and you
bring this opinion into the White House
what do you think uh he'll say to that
oh he oh he gets it I mean look
president Trump let's be very clear
about what president Trump is he's not
an interventionist but he's not a Tucker
in isolationist be very clear what he
did the guy who is Accused today of
being a Russian asset do you know what
we did when we found 300 Russians
running around Syria Wagner group guys
working for the crime you know we did
he called up Mathis and he said turn
them into Red Mist now Kill Them All
we killed 300 Russian soldiers in Syria
no president since the revolution of
1917 has killed hundreds of Russians in
wartime we did okay he's not an
isolationist what happened in Syria when
we saw the chemical this is Declassified
now I can talk about it what happened
when we saw the chemical weapons being
pulled out of that air base again to be
used against the civilians
over chocolate cake at Mar-A-Lago with
Xi Jinping eating his chocolate cake the
presently Lent over and said I just
launched fitted to cruise missiles on
that Syrian Air Base he's not interested
in Dumb Wars he's not interested in
fighting other people's Wars but when
you cross a line
we will make you extra crispy that's
president Trump strength through
leadership a peace through strength that
is look one of the most powerful moments
for me in the White House
as I went into the oval it was just me
and the president
and I have there to brief him on Iran I
think and he's very sidetracked he's
sitting sideways to the Resolute desk
he's reading some documents and out of
nowhere because I'm there to talk about
the Iran deal and killing it and he says
he looks up and he says Sebastian
I do not it was some Kim had just done
something
Sebastian I do not want to have
American GIS die on the Korean Peninsula
again
I mean he would just he just went so
heavy so fast
but if we have to go to war we will
that's who he is I don't want to but
only if it matters to our national
security that's why people don't
understand who he is you said Trump
wouldn't end the warm Russian Ukraine
how will he do that uh because that
because Putin's afraid of him think
think about what happened after we
killed 300 Russians working for the
Kremlin in Syria Putin didn't even have
a press conference
you didn't even have a press conference
you think Putin is afraid of him utterly
why is that afraid of trump
because he doesn't know what Trump's
going to do to him
I'll give you an idea CNN just announced
that they put 500 put and put 500 people
on the a list that you can visit uh
Russia I don't know if you saw that or
not who's on the list if you can pull
this up 500 names
uh Obama's on the list John huntsman's
on the list remember the form uh
Ambassador yes ambassador he's on the
list camels on the list camel Colbert's
on the list a bunch of guys are on the
list but uh Trump's not on the list so
you know who knows what this means but
this just came out a few days ago yeah
Obama is on the list Obama cannot visit
Russia
but Trump can Obama Colbert among 500
Americans banned from going to Russia
this just came out a couple days ago uh
yeah there it is that's the name so let
me wrap up with this story and then I
got a surprise for you I think you're
going to like our new thumbnail
I'm gonna lock it if he's not I guess
I've seen it I'm about to give it to you
to show I think this is legit and it's
the truth well we're about to die I did
this while we were talking
about our entirely working on this
thumbnail and the helicopter I'll be
here right after the show Biden gets low
rating on the common economy guns
immigration and AP uh Newark poll AP
News poll only 33 American adults
approve a president of mine's handling
of the economy while just 24 believe the
National Economic conditions are in good
shape furthermore only 31 approval
Biden's performance on gun policy and
immigration issues among them Democrats
the approval rating the higher but still
not overwhelming with approximately 61
percent approve approving of Biden's
handling of the economy 75 percent
approving of his overall job performance
however Democrats are more pessimistic
about the current state of the economy
only 41 percent dissatisfaction with
Biden's performance extends Beyond party
lines as even some of his supporters
Express frustration with the
post-pandemic situation and a lack of
bipartisanship in Washington they're now
saying it's the lowest approval rating
ever yeah in America uh if that's the
case one are the Dems gonna let them
really run are they going to get
creative the next 17 months because if
he does run this is not this is going to
be very easy like you said the one line
are you better off today than you were
four years ago that's the only question
I got asked right so is this is he
really going to be the candidate well
look I just want to know who the 31
percent is who are the 31 in America
First follow politics yeah but
of Biden's before
before
um you know it's not good for a former
strategist to the president to admit
this
I I don't have an answer that question I
asked this question every single day of
my producer how can they let this guy
run I mean you look at him just the last
two years just the mental and physical
deterioration him stumbling around Japan
him you know greeting dead people how do
you let this person run and the only
answer I have for you is there's really
no mechanism for an incumbent president
to be removed by his own party that the
Dan C can't have a vote and say you're
not allowed to run again the power of
the incumbency is almost total however
there is that very peculiar interview he
gave once where he said he was asked
what what happens this is when when
Obama came in he said what happens if
there's a disagreement between you and
Obama on policy do you remember this it
was creepy he said
I don't think we'll have a disagreement
but but if we do I'll come up with an
quote I'll come up with an ailment
and I'll retire
come up with an ailment
what the hell is that so is he are they
going to show him the video and say Hey
Joe it's time for you're the president
now but it's time for you to come up
with an ailment and then it's the
cackler then it's Kamala and it's going
to be even more fun than the debate you
think it should be required required to
take a mental and physical test open to
the public to to be disclosed no I just
should have to do that no I don't I
don't why because it's it's the will of
the people
Trump wants Biden
I'm confident Trump once Biden I'm
committed he's hoping I want you Rocky
three because that's it's not it's not
even a Rocky fight though because I
don't think he's this is not he's not
going against clever language he's not
going against he wants retribution no
yeah he and it's it's an easy matchup
for him because all he has to do is talk
a resume that's all he has to do okay
couldn't one argue that and the single
biggest indicator of trump over DeSantis
Biden would want Trump over like meaning
if if that if they're doing their
strategy meeting and Biden is saying
I think he screwed with either one of
them I think he screwed with either one
of it's just about who America wants
more I don't think he's in good shape
with either one of them so your latest
book The War for America's Soul uh uh uh
if we can put the link below for the
book the award for America's Soul as
well as the link to his go to my store
said gokastore.com for the FBI t-shirts
for the free Tucker t-shirts check them
out oh you've got the FBI t-shirt there
oh yeah yeah said gokastore.com it's our
hottest selling item until Tucker came
along oh and the transgender t-shirt
that my guy said would not sell it
number two t-shirt
don't be a science denial they said that
wouldn't sell that's a number two a man
is a man a woman is a woman
and and last but not least to make up
the the our marketing guys have been
working on this for the last two hours
hoping the new thumbnail is better Rob
drum roll show us what we got
uh that's the truth who is that that is
the truth the one and only but you could
have got a better one of you listen the
idea is to make you look good you're the
show I'm just a whole I lost 42 pounds
PVD Look at me now watch you know what's
gonna happen mainstream media is going
to say that's that's fake news but
that's the truth but I thought it's the
truth that's the truth it's right there
the muscles behind us Sebastian it's
been a blast having you on thanks buddy
uh uh people uh uh can listen to you
talk for hours uh not only from The
Voice standpoint but also from the
standpoint of how you break things down
uh looking forward to doing this again
with you here soon next 18 months
especially during this election run gang
uh we're about to announce the next live
text us the following this is what I
want from you the next slide we're going
to do at our Lounge slash Cigar Lounge
do you want it to be home team do you
want us to have a guest if yes who do
you want to have text award podcast to
310-340-1132 the word podcast to
310-340-1132 First text award podcast
then let us know what format you would
prefer having said that be sure to order
the book below
And subscribe to his website to his sub
stack I believe we're doing it again
tomorrow or am I out of town tomorrow
tomorrow
at 9 A.M Rob Smith from turning point
USA oh to home team we're going to do
with Rob Smith tomorrow and I'm going to
be in New York tomorrow night take
everybody bye-bye bye-bye